hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreign during again
and the June roadmap has finally
released today's Monday it I don't know
why they keep doing this stuff like days
before the Warriors then I don't really
care but happy Monday everybody oh yeah
we're gonna be going over what the June
roadmap is there's not much but I just
want to talk about it just in case and
kind of speculate when this new heroes
gonna release and maybe want some new
information will release about the
Viking hero so as always like to be if
you do enjoy subscribe for new a come
for the informational side a foreigner
that being the bell changes the hero
updates the patch notes the leaks if you
want to be kept up-to-date with
everything happening within the wall of
foreigner and never miss out on an
update definitely stay subscribe to the
channel my Twitter and discord will be
in the description down below and let's
get started with today's video so as I
said we have the June roadmap to go over
I'll flash it on screen and as you can
already tell there's not a huge amount
of stuff going on but on June 10th we
have the shadows of the heat soak eerie
event that's gonna be going on all the
way till June 27th one this little
infographic of her ends so a big
majority of June of course is going to
be of her which kind of sucks but no
problem here obviously this is gonna be
coming with the seasonal event the event
playlist new content of the week event
orders all that jazz all that good stuff
that we love to know about the events on
the 13th we got the arcade mode which is
Rio she's awakening on the 15th a couple
days ago we had the beginning of
campaign four so we're currently in
campaign four on the 20th on on Thursday
I do believe we're gonna be eating
Sakura's repentance another arcade quest
on the 21st we'll be getting an extra
loot fest that is going to be I believe
on Friday so if you want to get some
extra loot and this is perfect timing to
pair up with the two videos that I have
set up one of them going over all the
information and all the customization
options for the event and then how to
get those the fastest if you pair that
up with the extra loot you're gonna be
getting all that [ __ ] an hour so I
promise you that moving on towards the
very end of June we have the 27th and
that's going to be another Thursday
according to this there's going to be a
new content of the week no clue what it
is it might be a new emo to end us off
of the event or maybe something else
on the 27th there's also going to be an
arcade mode the maidens and fence alley
I believe I totally butchered that name
but there's another arcade quest and the
final one at the very end of the event
if you do want to play that for you
arcade owners coming June 28th we have a
ring to Vanquisher
challenged that's gonna be going from
June 28th to July 1st I think it's a
very hard to see from this graphic but
there will be a Vanquisher challenge
that usually has to do with takedowns in
a ranked mode so whoever whatever
faction happens to get that the most
will be getting an XP booster ward so
pretty nice for that and then I'm the
29th of June we have the year year 3
season 2 campaign 5 which is the very
final campaign for the entire season
which means after this is over we will
be getting new stuff on the hero now if
we do a little math and if you've been
playing the game for a long time you
know that just about every campaign is
about 14 to 15 days so roughly about 2
weeks this is going to be ending on a
Saturday which is the 29th of June and
if we go over to the calendar that I
have on screen for myself which
obviously you can pull this up for
yourself two weeks after the 29th is
going to be July 13 going to be the end
of season 10 and that's also a day
before my birthday shoutout for that but
you have to remember we are going to be
going into an off season I do not know
exactly how long that has been marching
fires was like three days whereas The
Wandering are Assassin's Creed event was
like an entire month so there is no
really set date on these types of like
off seasons so there is no concrete
evidence of how long this is going to be
do exactly pinpoint when it's going to
come out but assuming that it comes out
on the 13th just say just for the sake
of an example we get about two weeks
it's gonna be about July 27th is where
I'm around Rajal i 27th is going to be
the Saturday or if they want to push it
to a Tuesday or Thursday it could be the
25th or the 30th of July that's just my
interpretation if you look at the
roadmap way back in the very beginning
of this year where they showed all four
characters like when they're gonna come
out and then the events that are gonna
follow and stuff every single one of
them has two months listed so in for
season 11 or season 3 of year 3 it's
going with the Viking here that's going
to be July August is what it said and
then I do believe the other one is
October November or November December
that basically means that the character
is going to release at the end of the
first month and the beginning of the
second month so in this in this case it
means that the Viking hero is going to
be releasing at the end of July or the
very beginning of August the way I'm
going to basically
that is the 28th of July which is in one
certain week and then maybe the 6th of
August so roughly around there is when
the new hero might release I could
totally be wrong on this but I might
call it who knows if I'm pretty right on
a couple other things but that's going
to be my interpretation but usually
during the offseason and even right when
the campaign ends we get a lot of info
so expect somewhere around the beat
expect July to have some juicy stuff
coming we're gonna have a lot of
gameplay for the new character some of
the new rubrics coming for the
characters that are going to be getting
those reworks if they even have them of
course we're gonna be getting our
seasonal executions which is gonna be
awesome
I cannot wait to see what those are yeah
let me know what you guys think about
this stuff in the comments below I just
wanted to gauge everybody's opinions
engage everybody's thoughts this roadmap
is an incredibly detailed 90% of this
thing is the event and that's really it
sadly but I have a slight feeling that
July and August are going to be banger
months in terms of content like I said
we have the reworks if they happen to
have them we're gonna be having the
executions releasing the new hero all
that other stuff possibly new armor I
doubt it but it most likely be new
weapons but if there is new armor I'm
gonna complain of course but just to
recap really quickly this is all based
off of assumptions and just past events
that have happened in the game a long
time ago since the very beginning but I
have a slight feeling that the end of
season 10 is going to be Saturday July
13th and then we're gonna go into an off
season and the game and the season 11
will most likely come into the game
around July 28th - between that and
August 6th so that's going to be my
interpretation like I said complete
assumption could be totally wrong who
knows we might not even have an off
season this year I don't [ __ ] know
B I like the V if you do enjoy guys
subscribe for new I cover the
informational side a foreigner that
being the balance changes they hear
updates the patch it's in the leaks if
you want to be kept up-to-date with
everything happening within the world of
Warner I never miss out on an update
definitely subscribe the channel bye -
most OSA videos are going to be popping
up on screen guys if you want to check
those out and my Twitter and just grow
to be in the description down below and
with that peace out have a great rest
your day and enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]